hey everyone
welcome to the sim club
yay
simulation club
[Music]
it's so exciting for us
we've been across
patreon we've been across paypal
we've been across even cryptocurrency
and now to have the youtube membership
capacities
is so exciting
and bringing you
tremendous value
the sim club
tagline is devotion to truth
if that resonates with you
this is the place
to dive into the deepest depths
of what that means truly
epic perks all
proceeds funneled directly back into our
content
simply click join below the like button
and then select your tier let's go
through the tiers
the first tier is called the pupil
the price is 499
a month and the perk is access
to members only group chat
the description is a simulation private
community
group chat on god realization
spirituality
non-duality and the instructions are
simply to email us
at simulation series gmail.com after you
subscribe and we'll send you
the info to get into the group chat and
this is because
we would like to be notified by you as
well we will be frequently checking
on our end but we would like to be
notified by you just to make sure that
we see it and we get you in as soon as
quick
as soon as possible
now for those that
don't know what we will be discussing
in this community group chat just to
give you a little bit of a heads up
in terms of devotion to truth what we
mean is
the true understanding of the nature of
our reality
who we are why we're here
where we're going what this is all about
and we've firmly recognized
by analyzing the
perennial wisdoms across the planetary
mystic traditions
that they are all pointing to the same
one end from the different faces
of the mountain and the mountain is the
dualistic concession
that there is something to seek
and that is seeking enlightenment
whereas
the non-dual tradition says there is
nothing to seek
it simply is
and god realization being the process
of turning one's attention rather than
seeking externally
for happiness in the
illusory world of the creation design
rather turning one's attention inward
like in the parable of the prodigal son
onto consciousness or awareness itself
and therefore god realizing the diamond
necklace
that is already around each of our necks
and that the source light shines and
refracts
through each of those unique diamonds
and jewels
as a unique expression in this dreamed
creation design
we will also be continuing to not only
have the world leaders
on the show in these fields but also in
the cutting edge sciences we love
concepts like artificial general
intelligence we love the field of
biotechnology and neurotechnology and
neurolinks
we love the field of indistinguishable
virtual realities the future of
education with vr and ar and mixed
realities
we love the field of quantum computing
we love understanding our physics level
quantum mechanics we love to
dive into decentralization and
blockchains and cryptocurrencies
in the future of protocol research and
what that enables on a planetary level
for maximizing our prosperity also in
ecology
in solving the sustainable development
goals
eradicating poverty
creating
clean water
and sanitation clean and affordable
energy
we will continue honing in on that
as well as we hone in on the god
realization the spirituality and the
non-duality
and we will be doing it through myriad
methods of content
not only these fireside chat interviews
but we will also be doing it in these
direct transmissions
that come through this unit of atlas
as well as we will be doing it through
our
animated series chimps our anthologies
our documentaries
our projects around
the further dissemination
of these topics to
more people around the world and
increasing the efficacy
of that dissemination
so this is good you have a little bit
more
depth on our
both who we are and where we're going
which is ultimately what our channel is
up to sharing
that with you about the nature of
reality
of what is our true
nature what is the i
what is source what is god what is
infinity or the absolute
and what are these
creation designs
are we eternal yes
and can we
as we recognize that
effortlessly channel
the absolute highest morality into
our families our friends our community
the world
and architect those more abundant
frameworks and resource flows
to maximize our potential
what we're considering for this
tier with the members only group chat is
exploring
discord because it
is currently being used by many
of the other channels that we look up to
and it does a pretty good job at
breaking down
into the different channels
within the sim club
and using voice to be able to come in as
well
and being something that is both very
friendly on mobile
as well as is very friendly on a desktop
computer or a laptop computer or
even a tablet
and so we would love to hear how you
feel about
having that members only group chat
happening inside of discord
and also we would love to hear how you
feel about other
members only group chat platforms and
what you prefer
because we've also seen some of our
leaders
that we look up to doing
small group chats member only
in simple messaging
platforms and so there's that to explore
as well and that
seems a little bit more intimate as well
as a little bit more
concentrated on one topic which is quite
interesting
and maybe we do both so we would love to
hear from you
in the comments about what you would
like to see
all right so that's the first tier of
people
all right on to the second tier the
adept
the price is 9.99 a month and the perk
is that there's a shout out in
both the video as well as in the bio
the description is will shout out your
love and support
at the end of every fifth video we
publish
and the instructions are we'll check
this tier each time before we do a shout
out and we'll keep a ledger
this means just like you see here with
the text
we will have one of these for every
fifth video we publish shouting out
your love and support in the video as
well as we'll have that in the bio
it's pretty exciting become a part of
the channel's history
and i know many of you are across the
comments already
many of you have been with us for not
only
a month but many of you have been with
us for a year
some of you have even been with us two
years and more
and that's really cool because this is
really
our third year
of going with simulation
hard and it's really exciting
so so exciting 2018
was very formative
for us with some big interviews
launching us off getting our recording
studio in downtown san francisco and
this equipment to be able to
do 700 shows in two years
through 2018 and 2019 traveling to so
many cities and conferences to do these
action-packed days of interviews
just sponging up all of the wisdom
across
all of these different walks of life and
sharing that and so there's this
beautiful
archive of all of these interviews with
these diverse
minds from around the world that you can
go and revisit
and especially in 2020 taking the time
to synthesize the most profound things
that we had learned from them
and to distill that along with
analyzing the most genius
people that have ever lived as well as
the most enlightened and awakened people
that have ever lived and
abstracting out a meta pattern of
who they were and what they knew and
distilling that artistically
into our first book high-level
perception
and then moving to los angeles to
continue
this massive visionary journey
and being in love with every single
musical note
along the way and the silence between
them
riding the crest of the surf
in the now
it'd be an honor to have your support at
this level as well
this adept tier includes the pupil tier
which is great
and this tier is fun because it
really notches you in
to the history of the channel
all right and lastly
this tier's name is the sage
the price point is 24.99 a month
and the perk is that both exclusive
videos
as well as asking our interviewees
questions in the description is once per
month
we'll publish an exclusive video
and we'll choose the top three
questions from sages to ask
our guest and the instructions are we'll
send you the private video link each
month
and we'll also field your questions
three days before the show
so for those that are really interested
in the highest tier in
sage
it's super exciting because this is the
first systematized time that we're
opening
up a portal for
the our community and viewership to be
able to
send over really profound
questions and actually get them answered
by the guests
on the show so we will be
including in the time frame with the
guest
on the show the top three most profound
questions that are asked by the sages
and it'll be really exciting because
you'll get to know who they are ahead of
time you'll get to
figure out what kind of a profound
question to ask and send it over
we'll do our best to give you long
runways
so you know plenty in advance
and also we'll
keep the videos exclusive for a period
of time
and then we may choose to
make those exclusive videos public
down the line which will then enable
people to freely
access it which is the dissemination of
the expression that this is the wisdom
that it's communicating
and so it's important to also respect
that yes the first access is what you
get yet there's also the opening it up
downstream for people as well
and there's other exclusive benefits for
being a sage
that we are figuring out right now as we
are creating our
merch line so the simulation channel
sim club will have a merch line and that
merch line is going to be around
our tagline of devotion to truth
now devotion to truth is going to be
across all of these fields that we've
been describing
and making really cool cutting edge
symbols on art phrases
aphorisms on the clothing itself that's
really soft
and fun to wear
and showcase as you go throughout
the world where other people can see it
and be profoundly influenced by just
reading your shirt or experiencing your
shirt
and then the conversations that will
strike up around
that concept and the awakening being
accelerated
more and more of the veilless veils
being pierced to that god realization
and so the sage tier will include likely
several of those free merch items
per year which is fun
yay
and we're figuring out the other
benefits because there are
a lot of other really cool benefits
across these different clubs that we've
been analyzing
lots of the social media influencers and
icons and their unique clubs and what
they offer we've been analyzing them
and so there's a lot of unique things
that we're going to be contributing here
that are both different than those clubs
that are more honed in around devotion
to truth
and yet at the same time are leveraging
a lot of the same really strong
principles that they're using
so we're pumped to bring you massive
value and feel free to email us anytime
simulation series
gmail.com and we're so grateful for you
and enjoy
infinite love
again just a brief recap
again the tagline the devotion to truth
welcome to the sim club we would love to
have you
with these epic perks all proceeds
funnel directly back into our content
simply click click join below the like
button
and again these tiers the pupil tier
is gonna have at five dollars a month
access to the members only group chat
and again across the specific platform
or
platforms that we will be using we would
love to hear from you in the comments
below about what's ideal for you
what you think would optimize the
success of it
and then the second tier the ad up tier
at ten dollars a month which includes
the shout out in the video and bio
become a part of our history notched in
and the sage tier at 25
a month exclusive videos and ask our
interviewees questions
along with merch and a lot of really
cool other benefits that are coming
and that's all
we are ridiculously excited for
the sim club and
we are so pumped to have this
members of
our youtube channel be able to become
through this
join functionality a closer
connection into the essence of the
devotion to truth and into the essence
of piercing the veilus veil god
realizing
as well as architecting the more
prosperous and abundant future
that all of our hearts know is possible
we adore you infinite love
we hope you will join us
and thank you so
much absolute
infinite love
you